[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres ce soir nous recevons deux
écrivaines qui font revivre une
tradition littéraire française dont il a
finalement peu d'exemples modernes le
roman social le roman qui décrit les
milieux populaires elles ont bien des
points en commun d'abord c'est pour
l'une et l'autre leur premier roman
ensuite il est écrit en caméra
subjective c'est un monologue face à ces
vues du point de vue du narrateur et
enfin l'une et l'autre travaille leur
style elles font vraiment une oeuvre
littéraire elles ont une petite musique
bien à elle et cependant bien des choses
les séparent et d'abord le fait qu'elle
ne parle pas du même endroit et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui rend leur lecture
simultanée si passionnante l'une décrit
la classe ouvrière blanche qui vit dans
la France périphérique et l'autre les
milieux populaires
issus de l'immigration qui vivent dans
les quartiers urbains sensibles elle
n'écrivent pas non plus de la même
manière lorsqu'ils sont très différents
et leur point de vue est différent aussi
c'est ça qui va rendre la conversation
avec elle de à mon sens intéressantes y
a-t-il Diallo bonsoir
vous publiez deux secondes d'air qui
brûlent au seuil et vous y racontez une
bavure policière qui entraîne la mort
d'un jeune homme dans une cité nous
allons y revenir
claire Baglin bonsoir
vous vous publiez en salle aux Éditions
de Minuit et vous raconter la vie d'une
jeune salarié qui travaille dans un McDo
enfin vous dites un fast-food pour ne
pas le citer qui travaille dans un McDo
vous montrer comment elle rentre dans ce
dans cet univers comment elle y
progresse mais en parallèle
elle revient sur ses souvenirs d'enfance
dans sa famille
ses souvenirs de jeunes filles avec son
père Jérôme qui est ouvrier dans une
usine de maintenance automobile avec sa
mère Sylvie avec son frère Nico et c'est
ce parallèle entre ces deux univers qui
fait toute la musique du livre la
polyphonie du livre
alors le McDo c'est le point comme un
Fallou le fast-food c'est le point
commun de ces deux univers parce que il
est à la fois le lieu rêvé de la sortie
de la narratrice quand elle est jeune
avec sa famille et puis il est son
univers de travail quand elle devient
une jeune fille c'est d'abord en fait la
scène initiale effectivement de ce roman
qui a été presque la première en tout
cas dans l'écriture ou effectivement il
y avait vraiment ce fast food en commun
avec la sortie familiale et ensuite
l'embauche d'une équipe pierre mais
c'est vrai que ce qui m'intéressait
aussi c'était de faire sortir cette
famille donc comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure donc avec ces deux parents et
ses deux enfants de les faire sortir
aussi du fast-food pour aller vers autre
chose et cette autre chose qui
m'intéresse aussi et en fait les lieux
de vie de cette famille et vraiment en
fait aussi ce que ça dit sur leur façon
de s'approprier l'espace leur langage
leur façon d'évoluer en fait tout
simplement on va revenir un salon
ensuite il y a la description du McDo de
l'intérieur et ce qui est étrange dans
votre description c'est qu'elle est à la
fois
inquiétante et tendre c'est-à-dire que
c'est un univers épouvantable les tâches
sont parcellisées taylorisées il y a un
vocabulaire anglais on est très étrange
enfin c'est orwellien et d'un autre côté
toute la description et celle d'un
univers au fond assez chaleureux presque
fraternel enfin c'est deux choses en
même temps c'est de tonalité j'ai
l'impression en tout cas qui qui
cohabitent c'est vrai qu'en tout cas
dans dans le fast food comme comme je
l'appelle c'était aussi un choix ce
terme-là de fast-food parce que
j'estimais qu'en tout cas les marques
moments m'intéressaient vraiment pas
enfin littéralement je j'avais pas envie
de leur donner place et c'est vrai qu'il
y a ce côté très répétitif mais en même
temps dans dans le fast-food il y a
d'autres émotions du moment qui a fleur
et c'était ça aussi le sens de fast-food
au milieu de l'enfance comme ça c'était
aussi parler de des relations entre
employés entre équipiers d'ailleurs
comme c'est nommé et ce terme-là me
semble juste parce que justement on en
est équipé on entend l'équipe et chaque
élément fait partie de cette chaîne en
fait de de mouvement en fait chacun a
ses gestes qui amènent une commande et
une toute petite parcelle en fait de
chaque mais on voit tout de même à
travers le récit cette description qui
est fantastique je veux dire mais et la
comparaison avec les échantillons bref
qu'on a de la vie du Père qui est un
ouvrier du monde industriel traditionnel
on voit la différence tout de même entre
le monde industriel traditionnel et le
monde des services nouveaux les ouvriers
d'avant et les ouvriers d'aujourd'hui
parce que le monde que vous décrivez en
tout cas le monde du père est tout de
même plus collectif plus stable plus
solidaires plus paternaliste aussi alors
que le monde du fast food est beaucoup
plus précaire plus instable et plus
créer une concurrence entre les
équipiers on voit le changement
d'univers c'est quelque chose de très
différent en fait de toute façon je
pense que c'est aussi là que tiens
peut-être la différence entre le métier
et l'emploi c'est à dire que dans le
fast-food on serait sur un emploi
vraiment et on comprend étudiant
proprement étudiant et ça m'intéressait
aussi de dresser en comme ça une équipe
en fait d'étudiants c'est à dire qu'ils
savent que ils vont partir ils le savent
dès le début de l'entretien d'embauche
et il ne resteront pas et je pense que
c'est la différence peut-être
fondamentale entre le travail du Père et
le travail de la narratrice soit dans le
fast-food c'est que le père lui est là
et va rester là en fait et donc il y a
une il y a un ancrage qui peut
s'installer alors que fast-food il y a
quelque chose ou de toute façon rien ne
durera donc ça ça peut-être que il y a
aussi un impact sur la façon dont on
appréhende le travail à partir du moment
où on sait que ça ne verra que quelques
mois il y a peut-être un moment où
l'investissement ou du moins le la façon
de voir les choses et même l'observation
elle-même n'est possible que par cette
ce temps partiel en quelque sorte alors
dans les flashbacks dans les dans les
retours en arrière sur les souvenirs
d'enfance on voit le portrait de cette
famille ouvrière avec une série de
scénettes qui sont toutes merveilleuses
l'Odyssée pour aller au Mcdo la vie au
camping le dîner chez des copains le le
le la lecture le matin au petit déjeuner
des publicités
d'un côté ce sont des aussi médaillon
qui sont un peu comment dirais-je kitsch
il y a une culture populaire dont on
voit les limites mais en même temps vous
la regardez avec une immense tendresse
ça m'a fait penser au photographies de
Martine part ce photographe anglais qui
a photographié la classe ouvrière et on
voit à la fois le ce que les gens des
classes supérieures rappelleraient le
mauvais goût et en même temps quelque
chose de tendre d'attachant une il y a
un amour dans cette famille que qui
ressort à chaque instant de cette
description je tenais vraiment en tout
cas à ça et ça me touche que vous le
remarquiez c'est vrai qu'il y a j'avais
pas envie en fait de tomber dans quelque
chose qui soit par exemple avec un une
sorte de mépris comme ça ou du moins de
de regard déjà sur ça et qu'est-ce qui
serait bien et qu'est-ce qui serait
qu'est-ce qui serait quiche en fait je
par exemple je sais qu'il y a une scène
de comme ça de karaoké dans un camping
on pourrait se dire voilà ça va être le
lieu de mais en fait je trouve qu'il y a
autre c'est autre chose en fait j'avais
pas envie de d'avoir ce regard là ou du
moins de perpétue ce regard là j'avais
plutôt envie de revenir sur sur toute la
perception de l'enfant qui lui n'a pas
de regard en tout cas jugeant la
narratrice en fond ne considère pas ces
endroits comme je sais pas avec déjà
quelqu'un un mépris ou quelque chose
c'est juste un environnement des choses
qui viennent et une forme de beauté
aussi en fait dans dans cette atmosphère
mais elle perçoit tout de même qu'il y a
fleur une espèce une ronde sociale enfin
je sais pas comment l'appeler parce que
il y a tout un description du désordre
familial qui est merveilleuse d'ailleurs
le désordre chez la mère le désordre
chez les grands-parents comme si c'était
un très de la vie de la classe ouvrière
par rapport à l'ordre la propreté
bourgeoise mais en même temps elle n'a
pas le droit la narratrice de faire
venir des gens à la maison l'univers de
la maison est un univers clos comme s'il
y avait tout de même une intégration de
la honte sociale
j'employais pas trop ce terme de ondes
sociales je pense qu'en fait on est sur
une perception encore une fois d'enfants
sur un désordre mais le désordre il est
familial et reste dans la famille en
fait peut-être que justement dans ce
roman il y a un passage un peu il y a
une progression de l'âge en fait de la
narratrice elle devient adolescente à un
moment et peut-être que quand elle
devient adolescente et qu'elle arrive
chez une autre famille c'est là où
peut-être on comprend où on était avant
mais en tout cas quand il y a vraiment
un cercle clos ne l'enfant en fait au
tout début et c'est ça aussi qui est
très important c'est que les enfants
vivent dans des ordres ne saisissent
d'ailleurs pas très bien pourquoi on ne
doit pas faire rentrer des gens à la
maison véritablement et donc il y a pas
véritablement de honte en fait c'est
juste l'endroit où on évolue la façon
dont dont on vit et c'est plus tard
peut-être en confrontation qu'on peut
dire d'accord les autres ont d'autres
valeurs ou du moins d'autres façons de
percevoir les choses et je pense aussi
au fait que par exemple à côté de la du
désordre il y a la réparation qui est le
cœur du métier du père j'imagine qu'il y
a une dimension autobiographique dans ce
lit enfin c'est ça me paraît assez
évident est-ce que vous avez fait lire
ce livre à vos parents oui tout à fait
et alors quel a été leur réaction
comment ils ont perçu la façon dont vous
décritiez leur univers très bien en fait
c'est surtout que moi je tenais vraiment
en tout cas à avoir à leur proposer
cette lecture aussi histoire de savoir
qu'est-ce qu'elle était en quelque sorte
les choses qui qui pouvait les mettre
mal à l'aise mais en tout cas leur
lecture était pas n'a pas on va dire
déterminer les enfin le livre était
comme ça en fait et aller être comme ça
et d'une certaine façon ce qui me semble
très juste de leur attitude c'est que
c'est le sous-titre est bien roman et le
fait même que ce soit un roman il le
disent eux-mêmes c'est que voilà ça n'a
rien en fait ce livre n'a rien à voir
avec avec ma vie avec leur vie et déjà
un objet indépendant en fait et déjà
quelque chose d'extrêmement transformé
donc en fait d'une certaine façon ils le
perçoivent c'est que voilà
c'est quelque chose de différent c'est
c'est une une rien que la construction
par alternance produit aussi ce résultat
là et fait qu'en fait on est sur de la
de la grande fiction et même du grand
mensonge si je pourrais faire un peu ce
lien là c'est un mensonge en fait ce
livre en tout cas c'est une grande
déclaration d'amour
pas seulement à cette famille mais à cet
univers de la classe ouvrière qui est
d'ailleurs sans doute en train de
disparaître
je sais pas si elle disparaît en tout
cas elle est encore elle est encore bien
présente avec ses images et son imagerie
d'ailleurs aussi dans on voit les films
les documentaires c'est des il y a une
imagerie très forte tout ça et j'ai
l'impression que elle change mais la
condition ouvrière elle continue une
certaine façon
claire Baglin en salle c'est un livre
que j'ai trouvé remarquable avec un sens
inouï du petit février du détail
marquant de la saynète
et puis c'est une écriture sans aucun
jugement de valeur
sans aucun jugement son sang sans
sociologie presque champs psychologie
sans idéologie sans commentaire et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui donne à mon sens la
puissance de ce récit c'est que sous
l'apparente sécheresse de la narration
en fait il laisse venir une énorme
tendresse pour un monde une fois encore
qui n'est peut-être pas complètement
disparu mais mais qui en tout cas est
assez invisible pour reprendre une
expression qu'on utilise beaucoup
aujourd'hui Dieti Diallo
votre livre à vous deux secondes d'air
qui brûle au seuil et presque le
contraire de du récit de Claire je ne
parle pas du tout du talent je parle pas
du tout du talent je parle de la façon
dont vous abordez le sujet
d'abord ce que c'est pas la vie des
ouvriers blancs de la France
périphérique mais c'est la vie de la
jeunesse issue de l'immigration dans les
quartiers sensibles dans les quartiers
urbain sensibles mais ensuite c'est
parce que c'est un livre engagé c'est un
livre qui dénonce la violence policière
et qui dénonce la situation de
harcèlement tel que vous la percevez aux
jeunes des cités et puis votre écriture
n'est pas du tout l'écriture neutre de
Claire c'est au contraire une écriture
qui reprend en quelque sorte en tout cas
c'est le sentiment qu'on a l'oralité de
de cette jeunesse des quartiers que vous
décrivez qui reprend aussi sa culture la
culture urbaine sa musique et c'est un
long slam un long monologue par son par
le narrateur mais c'est comme ça que
vous allez raconter vous allez
développer votre récit mais commençons
par ce récit d'ailleurs donc c'est un
groupe de jeunes hommes
Astro chérie
et leur vie ordinaire va tout à coup
tourner au drame effectivement c'est
c'est un groupe d'amis parce que c'est
un roman dont on dit souvent qu'il parle
de violence policière c'est
effectivement le cœur le cœur du sujet
mais c'est aussi un roman avec une
un énorme focus sur les relations
amicales en quoi elles permettent
d'accéder à une forme de survivance
plutôt et donc c'est c'est ces
personnages oui Nil Astro Demba Issa qui
sont des jeunes hommes qui sont à
travers de
fabriquer leur âge adulte de fabriquer
leur
où est-ce que ça ce que ça comprend en
fait de passer de l'adolescence à l'âge
adulte avec avec énormément de
résonances politiques aussi puisque
c'est des c'est des garçons qui
fabriquent dans un contexte tout leur
corps sont stigmatisés à partir du
moment où ils sortent dans l'espace
public à partir du moment où il se
montre
on va les percevoir d'une manière qui
fait que
vivre normalement ça n'aurait pas trop
permis donc c'est c'est un peu
ce que je m'attache un peu à décrire
c'est comment en gros voilà certains
droits leur sont retirés et font que
leur vie sont modeler d'une manière et
puis une intervention de police va mal
tourner l'un d'entre eux va être
assassiné
et puis ils vont faire le deuil en
quelque sorte de ce de cet ami de ce
camarade qui est mort et puis il y a une
scène finale je laisse les lecteurs la
découvrir qui est comme le point d'orgue
du petite question pourquoi ce sont que
des hommes le narrateur est un homme
pourquoi c'est cet univers viril que
vous avez choisi de de comme décor alors
viril je sais pas effectivement il y a
peu de personnages de de femmes il y en
a deux sur lesquels je m'attarde un
petit peu et puis il y a aussi les des
groupes de femmes qui sont les voisines
les mers qui sont effectivement des des
personnages en toile de fond qui sont
plus des des groupes qui visent voilà
qui qui dont on comprend qu'elles
activent la cité dans le sens le lieu
politique warriver les choses
pourquoi avoir pas fait parler des
hommes et avoir parlé d'hommes c'est
parce que c'est à eux que ça arrive tout
simplement cette question de voilà de la
stigmatisation
des corps dans l'espace public qui donne
lieu à du harcèlement policier c'est à
eux que ça arrive en premier lieu et
puis la d'autres personnes après aussi
mais en premier lieu ça veut que ça
arrive et comme j'avais l'envie d'écrire
un roman qui soit
antispectaculaire qui soit qui soit en
creux un peu du discours médiatique
qu'on peut
entendre autour de la question des
violences policières qui vise voilà
spectacularisé les les notamment les
réactions dans les quartiers populaires
je
j'avais envie d'un geste qui part de
l'intériorité et ça me semblait de fait
évident de faire parler du coup des
principaux concernés puisque voilà
c'était et d'ailleurs vous les décrivez
ce groupe de jeunes gens ils sont
tendres ils sont doux ils aiment
ils ont des savoir-faire d'ailleurs pas
forcément les soirs à faire dans
lesquels on met un diplôme mais ils ont
des savoir-faire que vous décrivez
vous avez voulu les décrire d'une
manière qui contraste avec le stéréotype
qu'on se fait de ces jeunes gens des
banlieues vous avez voulu les décrire
d'une manière tendre et douce et pas
comme des jeunes gens violents pour
contraster avec l'idée que comme ça
l'idée qui traîne sur eux
oui et non c'est j'irai même plutôt non
c'est que tout simplement je les ai
décrits tels que je les perçois je les
ai décrits tels que on se ressent nous
on n'est pas des sauvages quoi du coup
c'est un peu c'était un peu ça l'idée
c'est que
moi j'ai après c'est vraiment mon avis
mais j'ai l'impression que dans le
milieu de la littérature dans les
productions littéraires il y a quand
même une sur-reprétation de point de vue
qui ne sont pas les nôtres on est très
peu de personnes racisées à pouvoir
prendre la parole
littéralement
et du coup voilà je pense qu'on est
vraiment des générations qui avons
souffert de ça et arriver avec ce livre
c'était aussi une manière de de se dire
de l'intérieur de donner son point de
vue son sa version des faits d'une
certaine manière et c'est surtout ça
mais moi j'avoue que en cours de route
je me suis rendu compte que j'avais une
envie c'était celle de plus m'adresser à
j'avais pas envie que ce livre ça soit
une adresse à des personnes qui me
dominent qui nous dominent j'avais pas
envie j'avais plutôt envie que ça soit
un livre pour celles et ceux qui sont
dominés
par et pour celles et ceux qui sont
dominés en premier lieu évidemment après
un lit circulaire mais et c'est pour ça
que vous avez choisi une forme
stylistique
qui est si proche avec un vocabulaire
vernaculaire enfin le vocabulaire des
cités parfois difficiles à comprendre
pour des gens qui n'en sont pas une
musicalité d'ailleurs la musique est
extrêmement présente dans le il y a même
une playlist à la fin dans laquelle il y
a beaucoup de rap et beaucoup de de
techno ou d'électro c'est pour ça que
vous avez choisi ce style qui est le
disons ce que les Américains appellent
la littérature urbaine le fait que non
seulement vous racontez leur vie de
l'Intérieur tel que eux se vivaient pas
tel qu'on les représente mais dans leur
langue à eux
c'est ma langue à moi surtout c'est
c'est pas quelque chose de très réfléchi
alors évidemment quand on écrit un livre
on choisit beaucoup de choses qui
sortent de manière très spontanée enfin
en tout cas moi la manière dont j'ai
écrit ce livre
et puis ensuite on ensuite on se met à
discourir dessus parce que parce que
voilà il faut il faut pouvoir
créer de la pensée autour de ce qu'on a
de ce qu'on a rédigé mais
si je dois parler du geste initial avant
que avant que je fasse des connexions
mais qui me permet de voilà de prendre
du recul et de le considérer de
l'extérieur ce geste c'est plutôt que ça
me semblait pas ok en fait de parler
dans une d'écrire dans une autre langue
que celle avec laquelle je m'exprime
ça sonnait faux de toutes les enfin ça
aurait son défaut de toutes les manières
je pense
ou en tout cas ça n'aurait pas sonné
spontané et moi j'avais envie d'une
langue dans laquelle je me sente à
l'aise aussi une langue qui qui
représente bien
l'hybridité avec laquelle on se fabrique
et aussi c'est moi ce qui me passionne
dans dans la langue en général et dans
celle que que nous qu'on peut employer
dans les quartiers populaires même dans
les milieux populaires en général c'est
ce passage qu'on fait d'enregistrer à
l'autre et
on a aucune peine à passer d'un registre
alors peut-être pas soutenu mais en tout
cas voilà de pouvoir parler dans une
langue qui nous permet de passer des
entretiens d'embauche et en même temps
voilà une langue qui nous permet de nous
exprimer les uns avec les autres dans un
dans un registre qui est de l'ordre de
l'intention beaucoup en fait
c'est des langues qui vont avec des
accents et qui vont aussi avec des des
expressions faciales et des choses comme
ça donc j'avais un peu envie de
reproduire ça deux secondes d'air qui
brûle c'est une plongée dans la tête
dans la vie dans la langue des jeunes
des quartiers
peut-être le premier texte en France de
ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure qui
existe aux États-Unis et qu'on appelle
la fiction
urbaine
lecture passionnante je dois le dire
mais nous n'avons pas fini avec vous
avec vous deux d'abord mais avec vous
diatti en particulier parce que dans Au
Bonheur des livres nous nous donnons la
parole à nos lecteurs le bonheur des
livres c'est d'abord le plaisir des
lecteurs et l'un d'entre eux l'un
d'entre elles en l'occurrence nawell a
une question à vous poser mais ouais on
vous écoute
[Musique]
bonjour Alors moi je m'appelle Nawel
j'ai 23 ans et j'habite à Paris je suis
passionnée par la littérature depuis
l'enfance donc je suis intéressée par
tous les genres et je lis dans les deux
langues donc en français et en anglais
je recommande notamment la librairie
shakespean Company qui se situe aussi à
Paris donc voilà la littérature ça a
toujours été quelque chose
qui a été en moi depuis l'enfance donc
une vraie passion
alors aujourd'hui je souhaiterais
recommander un livre nommé journal d'un
borderline donc écrit par un jeune
auteur qui quant à lui se nomme Alex
Hobb donc sorti par Eddy livre février
dernier donc c'est l'histoire d'un jeune
homme donc atteint de la maladie mentale
borderline qui raconte ses péripéties à
travers un journal intime ce qui permet
à la fois au lecteur atteint par cette
maladie mentale de s'y reconnaître de
s'y identifier et à la fois au lecteur
n'y connaissant pas grand chose dans la
prendre davantage à travers un point de
vue interne ce que j'ai trouvé fascinant
bonjour diatie Diallo alors j'ai trouvé
votre livre très très intéressant Jérôme
j'ai notamment remarqué une richesse de
langage impressionnante ainsi que la
thématique du son du bruit de la musique
du fait de se faire entendre de faire
passer un message
ce qui m'amène à vous demander à qui
vouliez vous faire passer ce message
particulièrement concernant les
violences policières en banlieue
parisienne
alors y a-t-il vouliez faire passer un
message vous vouliez écrire
les deux mon capitaine
alors faire passer un message je ne sais
pas trop je répète souvent que j'ai pas
écrit ce livre pour partir en croisade
après c'est un livre qui est quand même
effectivement très politique moi je
dirais que je suis plus partie du
constat que la question des violences
policières elle
surexistait dans les médias et on l'a
traitait mal à mon sens elle existait
beaucoup aussi dans la dans une
production plus théorique en sciences
humaines notamment mais que finalement
elle sous-existait dans des productions
littéraires et je me suis posé la
question de pourquoi et
sachant que à mon sens la fiction c'est
vraiment un espace qui permet de créer
des possibles politiques de penser de
prendre du recul sur le réel et ça moi
en tout cas en tant que laiterie ça m'a
permis parfois de mieux penser ma
condition et
d'analyser les voilà les phénomènes qui
m'entourent sur un plan politique et
voilà partant de ce constat j'avais
envie de
matelas à la tâche lourdes mais de voilà
d'arriver avec un récit une histoire
en espérant qu'il y en a d'autres qui
suivront
très bien alors on peut pas inviter tout
le monde malheureusement mais on peut
parler des livres qu'on aime en plus des
auteurs qu'on a invités et notamment
vous quel est le livre qui vous a
beaucoup plus et en étant attention
c'est satisfait ou remboursé
nous ceux qui nous écoutent doivent
adorer le livre que vous allez leur
proposer je vous mets la pression on
commence par vous d'y être quel est le
livre que vous avez envie que nous
lisions et bien c'est un livre qui est
sorti il y a pas très longtemps aux
éditions du commun qui s'appelle suite
des colonial écrit par Olivier Marbeuf
et c'est un livre que je suis en train
de dire je n'ai pas fini mais qui que
j'aime beaucoup parce qu'il
il est très hybride en fait il sort
entre les styles on est vraiment sur à
la fois un essai théorique biographique
mais aussi une quelque chose qui est
très haut compte à la prose poétique et
qui dit aussi voilà ce que c'est de
penser
le geste artistique et le monde aussi
depuis les marges et Claire quel est le
livre que vous souhaiteriez que lisions
il y a beaucoup de livres je pense qu'il
faudrait lire effectivement après moi ma
dernière lecture ça a été un livre assez
étonnant de Karen Menin qui s'appelle
qui s'appelle Nam noir et en fait elle
fait un récit vraiment très curieux sur
justement un parcours où la croyance à
sa place et elle essaie de cerner en
quelque sorte son nom d'intérêt pour
enfin du moins ça non croyance
d'encerner les contours véritablement
très bien alors au bonheur des livres on
a choisi pour vous enfin on vous en tout
cas on a aimé le cas Victor sommaire
c'est un premier roman hitch coquin que
Amélie Nothomb trouve remarquable ça
vous amuse hop je vous l'offre la vie
est pas l'air trait de mondeuse mais
c'est pas grave tenir sa langue Paulina
panason les Russes c'est pas seulement
Poutine c'est le récit d'une immigration
et c'est la vie entre deux langues c'est
un très beau vous avez commencé
pour vous aussi ah bah vous aussi bon
ben je regarde
mode Simoneau l'heure des oiseaux ça
raconte la vie sans doute de ses parents
de de ce qui s'est passé dans ces dans
ces internats à Jersey où les enfants
ont été martyrisés c'est à la fois
sévère mais je mais très touchant
allez voilà et alors une bande dessinée
qui raconte la vie de Jimmy Hendrix
c'est Yazid Manou qui en a fait le texte
un journaliste spécialisé et Jimi
Hendrix 4 ans il a il a il a joué de la
guitare pendant quatre ans et il a
révolutionné la pop music quand les
Clapton les Beatles les Stones ont
écouté la première fois à Londres ils
sont restés ass ce type est un génie et
moi-même le premier disque de pop que
j'ai acheté de ma vie j'avais 12 ans
c'était
un cdisk et j'ai été déchiqueté et donc
en plus la vie de ce type est
extraordinaire donc de se guitare héros
une BD à raconter
voilà merci cette émission est terminée
merci à Claire bagelin et à diati DALO
Diallo pardon dont le talent pas le
nombre des années et qui chacune nous
plonge dans la vie des classes
populaires dans deux univers différents
chacune avec beaucoup de talents merci à
Nawel notre lectrice merci à vous qui
nous avait suivi vous pouvez revoir
cette émission soit sur le site de
Public Sénat soit sur votre plateforme
préférée sous la forme d'un podcast et
puis nous nous retrouvons la semaine
prochaine même chaîne même jour même
heure à moins que d'ici là nous ne nous
soyons croisés dans une librairie merci
et bonsoir
[Musique]